a program that would pair service dogs
with veterans to help treat mental
illness is moving through congress
the bipartisan bill just passed in the
house this week and could make it onto
the president's desk by memorial day
kelly meyer reports on the push to get
this man's best friend
to those in need four-legged friends
took over capitol hill this week to
highlight a need to help
service members we lose 22 veterans a
day to suicide
it's time to fix it ohio republican
congressman steve stivers is pushing for
his paws act
to create a pilot program giving
veterans access to service dogs the dogs
are trained to do things like
block a veteran to give them space in a
crowd or wake them up if they're having
a nightmare
they're getting people away from their
night terrors they're getting them out
of the house they're helping them
socialize
for florida republican congressman mike
waltz a combat veteran
the support is life-saving time and time
again
veterans are sharing with me that it
gets them off the meds and once the
program is over
the veteran can adopt their dog to
continue providing this crucial support
300 lawmakers worked across the aisle to
get this passed in the house
including michigan democrat alyssa
slotkin i have gotten a chance to visit
and seen with my own eyes
what the impact of a dog plus a veteran
who is suffering
can have the legislation is now on the
fast track
in the senate and republican north
carolina senator tom tillis tells me
he hopes it will pass in time for
memorial day i think it's a very
important time for us to recognize the
life-saving
consequences of this therapy this is
stiver's last bill before he retires
and he believes after a six-year push it
will finally make it to the president's
desk
things take a long time in washington
you just have to be dogged
and stay with it reporting in washington
i'm kelly meyer